The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So this is our last
10.34 lecture of the year.
And we're just going
to use it for review.
So I'm going to give a
brief recap of the course.
We've done a lot, actually.
I hope you've learned a lot
over the course of the term.
We've had lots of
opportunities to practice
with different
numerical methods.
I've checked in
from time to time
on the homework submissions.
I've been really impressed
with the quality of the work
that the class has
produced as a whole.
It tells me that you
guys do understand
what you're doing, that you can
apply these methods to problems
of engineering interests.
And I hope that
the things you've
learned over the
course of the term
can be applied to your
research down the road.
Right, that's sort
of the goal here.
Whether you do experiments
or modeling or theory,
at some point, computation
is going to play a role.
You should feel comfortable
after that things
that we've done in this course
on reaching back to these tools
and utilizing them to either
solve simple transport
models of a drug delivery
problem that you're working on,
or fitting data reliably, doing
hypothesis testing of models
versus data.
You have the tools
now to do that.
The homework
assignments that you've
completed over the
course of the term
sort of lay out the framework
in which that can be done.
And you seem very competent.
We'll test that competence
on the final exam, which is
Monday from 9:00 to 12:00 AM.
It's not in Walker, though, OK.
It's in 56-154.
I'll remind you of
that again at the end.
But it's not in Walker, so
don't show up there at 9:00 AM.
You'll be taking the
wrong final exam.
It's in 56.
There's going to be a review
session with the TAs on Friday.
It's going to be in this room.
It's going to be from
10:00 to 12:00 AM.
And the TAs asked me
to ask you to review
your grade on Stellar.
Make sure that everything
is entered accurately.
So check that your assignment
grades match the grades that
are entered there.
Check that your quiz grades
match the grades that
are entered there.
You're going to take
your final on Monday.
And we're going to
grade it on Tuesday
and submit your final
grades, because some of us
have to travel right after
the final exam period.
So we want to make
sure everything
is as accurate as possible
when we enter the final data.
OK?
Good.
OK, so a course recap.
We've done a lot this
term, actually, right?
You should be really
pleased with yourself
for having made it this far.
Any one of these subjects
could comprise an entire course
in and of itself.
And you've gotten a broad
overview of all of them.
So I'll remind you.
We started with linear algebra.
I told you the first
day that linear algebra
would be the underpinning
of all the numerical methods
that we utilized along the way.
And that was true.
I didn't lie.
You really wanted to
understand linear algebra well
if you were going to solve
any problems numerically.
We moved on to things
that were more interesting
from an engineering context,
systems of nonlinear equations
and optimization.
So being able to solve
engineering problems, being
able to do engineering
design by optimizing over
various uncontrolled degrees
of freedom is important.
And we did both constrained
and unconstrained optimization.
Then we moved on to dynamics.
We did ODE initial
value problems
and DAEs, which are the
combination of nonlinear
equations and initial
value problems.
We discussed boundary
value problems
and partial differential
equations, which largely
are a class of boundary value
problems as well, at least
the ones that chemical engineers
are typically interested in.
And we switched a little bit.
We went into probability
and models and data.
And then we came
back to more modeling
in the form of
stochastic simulation.
And all along, this was threaded
through with lots and lots
of MATLAB.
So hopefully, you
learned to do programming
if you didn't know that before.
MATLAB's actually a very useful
programming tool to know.
It's not so specific.
There aren't specific
quirks and details
you need to understand
like you would
with a lower level programming
language like C or Fortran.
It's very high level, and the
concepts that you utilize there
can be translated to other
programming languages as well.
So you may find at some point
in your research you want
to do a lot of data handling.
MATLAB's not great for
handling data actually.
Parsing large data sets is
quite difficult in MATLAB.
But there are tool kits that
are built into programming
environments like
Python that are
very efficient at doing that.
And Python is also underpinned
by similar numerical methods
that are readily accessible.
Everything you learned in MATLAB
can be applied there as well.
So you should have a
broad understanding
of how to draft an algorithm,
how to modularize code,
how to integrate several
different numerical methods
together to form a solution
to a more complex problem.
So we did linear algebra.
This was the basis of all
the problem solving we did.
Principally, it was
concerned with the solution
of systems of linear equations,
though oftentimes, that's
sort of disguised.
It isn't a direct system
of linear equations
we're trying to solve.
But somehow, we need
to decompose a matrix.
And in the process
of decomposing it,
we're essentially doing solution
of systems of linear equations.
One thing we're
really concerned with
was how linear
algebra operations
scale with the
size of the problem
that we're interested in.
The bigger the system
of equations gets,
the slower the calculation
is going to be.
And how slow can that get?
This will introduce
fundamental limits
on what we can do
computationally.
When we try to solve partial
differential equations,
and we decompose them
into linear equations,
and we have huge
numbers of states
that we'd like to
be able to resolve
with a partial
differential equation,
the problem can get
so complex so fast
that a computer
can't approach it.
So being able to estimate
the computational cost
of these operations is critical
for deciding whether a problem
is feasible or unfeasible.
You'd like to know
that before you
start writing down a numerical
solution to the problems.
We focused a lot on that.
There was fundamentals
like arithmetic,
solving linear equations
numerically using Gaussian
elimination, for example.
We discussed decomposition
in the form of eigenvalues
and eigenvectors and, more
generally, the singular value
decomposition.
And we discussed briefly
iterative solutions
of linear equations.
That was sort of our segue
into iterative solutions
of nonlinear equations as well.
So that was things
like the Jacobi method
or the Gauss-Seidel
method, which
were ways of the really
operator-splitting methods
of the same sort of class as
we talked about in PDEs, where
we took that matrix and we
split it into different parts.
We split it in a
way that would make
it convenient to solve a simpler
system of linear equations.
And depending on the
properties of the matrix,
that solution might be
achievable or not achievable.
The iterative method
may not converge.
But for certain
classes of problems,
we could guarantee
that it would converge,
and it might do it very quickly.
Things we didn't cover, but
that are important, I think.
There's a notion called
linear operator theory,
which is an extension of linear
algebra to infinite dimensions.
You've seen some of this
already in your transport class,
for example, where you
solve differential equations
with sets of functions.
You have some infinite
set of functions
that you solve a
differential equation with,
an ordinary
differential equation
or a partial
differential equation.
And all of the
underpinnings of that
fall under linear
operator theory,
which is an extension of
what you've learned already
for linear algebra.
We talked about Gaussian
elimination and the LU
decomposition.
You'll find in the
literature there
are lots of matrix
decomposition methods.
And the ones that
are chosen are chosen
for often
problem-specific reasons.
So there's things like
the QR decomposition
or the Cholesky decomposition
or the Schur decomposition.
These are technical terms.
You can look them up.
And you should feel confident
that, if you read about them,
you should be able
to understand them
given the basis in linear
algebra you have now.
But we didn't look at
those in particular.
And the state of the art in
linear algebra and solving
systems of linear equations
lies in what I refer
to as Krylov subspace methods.
We talked about
conjugate gradient
as an iterative method
for linear equations.
There's a broader
view of that that
says Krylov subspace method.
You may see that in the
literature from time to time.
It's a more nuanced discussion
of the linear dependence
of columns in a matrix
or linear independence
and how you can take
advantage of that
to rapidly generate iterative
solutions to those equations.
Any questions about
linear algebra?
No?
Things are clear.
You've done a lot
of it this term.
Systems of nonlinear equations.
So these are, of
course, essential
for any engineering problems
of practical importance.
Linear equations tend to
be easy to solve overall.
Most engineering problems
that are interesting
are nonlinear by nature.
That's what makes
them interesting.
And we also saw later
on that solving systems
of nonlinear equations
was intimately
associated with optimization.
And so we discussed fundamentals
like convergence of sequences
and the rate of convergence
of those sequences,
stopping criteria for
iterative methods.
The best sort of
nonlinear equation solvers
with multiple equations
and multiple unknowns
are Newton-Raphson-type methods.
They're the ones that
are going to, if we're
close enough to a solution, give
us quadratic convergence, which
is often more than we deserve.
It's exceptionally fast, but
it's not a globally convergent
sort of methodology.
So we also discuss
quasi-Newton-Raphson methods
that can help enhance the
convergence of Newton-Raphson.
And then we knew that we
needed good initial guesses
for solving these problems.
We don't know how many
solutions there are.
We have no idea where
they're located.
And so we talked about
homotopy and bifurcation
as ways of generating
those initial guesses
and ways of tracking multiple
routes or multiple solutions
to the system of equations.
I mentioned briefly
during that lecture
the concept of arclength
continuation, which
is a more advanced sort
of homotopy method.
And we didn't get to
discuss that in detail
because, actually, the
underlying equation
for arclength
continuation is a DAE.
OK, it's a fully
implicit DAE that one
has to solve in order to track
the solution path as a function
of the homotopy parameter.
So we didn't cover this.
We didn't try to solve
any arclength continuation
problems.
So it's a very
common method that's
applied to solutions
of nonlinear equations.
Then we moved on
to optimization.
So we need this for design.
We use this for model fitting.
And we discussed both
unconstrained and constrained
optimization.
In the unconstrained context, we
derived optimality conditions.
How do we know that
we found the solution
to this problem, at least
a locally optimal solution?
And then we discuss
steepest descent methods
that could get us
to that solution
with linear conversions.
We discussed
Newton-Raphson methods
that can get us to that solution
with quadratic convergence.
We discussed dogleg methods
that are heuristic by nature,
but meant to mix the
properties of steepest descent
and Newton-Raphson to give us
reliable convergence no matter
how far we are
from the solution.
We moved on to
constrained optimization.
Those problems came
in two types, right,
equality constraints and
inequality constraints.
And we discussed the
method of Lagrange
multipliers to handle
equality constraints.
We discussed interior
point methods
to handle inequality
constraints and their mixture
to handle a combination
of equality and inequality
constraints.
We left out a lot.
Optimization is a huge field.
So there are special
classes of problems
called linear
programs, which are
solved in a particular fashion.
These are problems that have a
linear dependence on the design
variables.
There's problems
called integer programs
where the design variables can
only take on integer values.
These might be very important.
You can imagine trying
to design a plant
and asking what integer
number of heat exchangers
or separators is optimal.
Associated with constrained
optimization and inequality
constraints, there
is an equivalent set
of optimality conditions
that we didn't try to derive.
Their called the KKT conditions.
So this comes up a
lot in literature.
So it's sort of the
fundamentals of knowing
that you found the
optimum to the inequality
constrained problem.
They're not difficult to derive.
But we have a limited
amount of time in the class.
It's something fundamental
that's sort of missing.
And then these sorts of methods
of all find local optima.
But oftentimes, we're interested
in global optimization instead.
And that's not something
that we discussed at all.
That's quite complicated and
beyond the scope of the course.
But things like genetic
algorithms, that's
a term that will come up a lot.
That's one way of
trying to seek out
global optima in a landscape.
ODE-IVP, right, so now we want
to move from static engineering
situations to dynamics.
And we were really
concerned, when
modeling dynamics,
with both the accuracy
and the stability
of these methods.
We were concerned
about stability
with other algorithms,
too, for solutions
of nonlinear equations.
We were concerned with whether
the Newton-Raphson method would
converge or not.
That's a stability
issue in a sense.
OK, so we're concerned
with stability there.
But here we really
focused on it in detail,
in part because some of
these differential equations
are inherently unstable.
In engineering
circumstances, that happens.
And we would be unwilling
to accept unstable solutions
in situations where the
equations themselves
are stable.
In the case of
Newton-Raphson, we
can do these sorts of
quasi-Newton-Raphson methods
to change the path
the solution follows.
And we didn't really care
what path it followed.
But here, the path is important.
We're not free to
change the path.
So the method itself has
to be inherently stable.
So we discussed
numerical integration.
We discussed two classes
of method, explicit methods
and implicit methods.
So explicit methods,
we mentioned
these explicit
Runge-Kutta formulas
that have been derived
for all sorts of accuracy
levels, both local truncation
error and global truncation
error.
Explicit methods,
unfortunately you
can't guarantee that
they're always stable.
They lack a property
called A stability.
Implicit methods,
on the other hand,
can be made to be stable
under all circumstances.
So one of those is the
backward Euler method.
That's a nice one to use.
The penalty for using these
implicit methods is you
likely have to solve a nonlinear
equation at each time step.
So there is a cost
to pay associated
with enhancing stability.
We discussed local and
global truncation error.
And we talked about stiffness
and linear stability criteria.
So linearizing the ordinary
differential equation,
assessing what the eigenvalues
associated with the Jacobian
of that linearization is.
And using those
eigenvalues to tell us,
for example, what kind of time
steps we need with our method
in order to achieve stable
integration in time.
Things we didn't cover that are
sort of interesting and maybe
important in engineering
context, one of those
is event location.
You may want to know the time
at which something happens.
So I may want to know
when does the solution hit
a certain point in time.
Maybe, I even want to change my
dynamics when the solution hits
a particular point in time.
There's a broader class of
methods that can do that.
They're built into
MATLAB too, actually.
You can set up these events
and have the dynamics change
or have a report that
an event occurred.
But we didn't really
discuss that at all.
And in numerical
computing, parallelization
is important for studying
classes of big problems.
It's sort of funny,
but you can even
do parallelization in time.
So this is something that's
been discussed for a long time.
And for certain
classes of problems,
it offers computational
advantages
over serial integration of
the dynamics an ODE-IVP.
So you can imagine how do
you parallelize in time.
So you can take the time window
that you're interested in
and cut it up into
different slices.
And you could try to solve in
parallel the dynamics over each
of those slices.
But for each slice, you need
an initial condition that
has to be precisely prescribed.
And you don't know those
initial conditions.
That's what the serial
integration would tell you.
One way of doing parallel
in time is to say, well,
those initial
conditions are unknown.
And they match up to
the terminal conditions
of the previous slice.
So why not wrap this
serial integration process
in a Newton-Raphson solver to
determine each of these points?
With certain
classes of problems,
certain ODE-IVPs that
are inherently stable,
you can do that.
And you can get a computational
speedup over serial integration
just by doing the
integration for each
of the slices on
different computers
and bringing all of
the results together.
The bigger the farm of computers
you have, the more slices
you can utilize.
That's sort of
interesting, right?
Parallel in time, it's
bizarre, because we usually
think of time integration
as being sort of causal.
I have to know where I was
to predict where I'm going.
But you can actually
divide these things up
in more sophisticated ways.
We talked about BVPs and PDEs.
We treated them as the same
class of problem broadly.
Usually, when chemical engineers
are looking at these problems,
we're interested in
spatial variation
of some sort of a conserved
quantity, so momentum
or energy or concentration
of a species or mass.
And here we are also concerned
with both the accuracy
and stability of
method stability
now for when we had
also time integration
of the solution, in addition
to spatial variation.
And so for BVPs, we talked
about shooting methods.
So can I recast a boundary
value problem in one dimension
as an initial value
problem with an unknown?
That's a very common way
of solving these problems.
And they are sometimes
stable and sometimes not.
When they're
unstable, you can do
what's called multiple shooting,
where you divide the domain up
into subdomains, and you shoot
from the initial condition
of each of those subdomains.
It looks exactly like the
parallel in time integration
that I described for you before.
And then you try to match
up the initial conditions
with the terminal conditions
to get a continuous solution.
Then we discussed
relaxation methods
for solution of BVPs and PDEs.
So collocation, Galerkin.
Collocation, you'll
recall, was we
want to try to
satisfy the governing
equation at various points
in the solution domain.
So we might write our
solution as the superposition
of a set of functions.
And then try to satisfy
at various points
that we've laid
out in the domains.
Maybe, there's even
an optimal place
to put all these points
in order to minimize
the error in the solution.
Galerkin, instead,
we tried to make
the projection of the
error in our equations
on different orthogonal
functions that represented
the solution be zero.
So that was sort
of a global error
that we tried to minimize over
different orthogonal functions.
Whereas collocation is
sort of a local error
that we're trying to
minimize, a local truncation
error that we're
trying to minimize.
We discussed finite difference
and finite volume methods
as well.
So ways of discretizing
in the equations.
Finite difference, I would
say, is the easiest one
to reach for.
If you had to pick a
quick and dirty method
to try to get a solution,
finite difference
can be really easy to go to.
It's easy to figure out
how big the errors are
in your finite
difference method.
But it may not be the optimal
approach to the problem.
For certain geometries,
finite volume
is really far more
preferable, because it's
easy to estimate the
fluxes through surfaces
of funny shapes where
your grid shape now
conforms to your geometry.
Finite volume also
had the advantage
of being strictly conservative.
So I can never gain or
lose a conserved quantity
in the finite volume
method, at least
to within the numerical error.
And that isn't true of finite
difference or finite element.
So if I'm concerned
about those things,
finite volume is really
the approach to use.
And you'll find one
fluid mechanical solver
that's freely available.
You can go download
and use it today,
and it is widely used in
research, is OpenFOAM.
And that's all based on
the finite volume method.
So they're trying to conserve
momentum, conserve mass,
and conserve energy
associated with the fluid.
OpenFOAM is good at drawing
bizarre grids of the domain
and giving you very
accurate integration
of fluid mechanical equations.
And it's good at doing that
because it uses finite volume.
You discussed the
method of lines,
which was a way of discretizing
space, but leaving the time
dimension undiscretized and
then applying ODE-IVP methods
for solving in time.
It's an incredibly useful way
to approach those problems.
Because it leverages expertise
in two different techniques.
There are specialized methods
for doing time integration
with some spatial
discretization that
are vetted for their stability
properties and their accuracy.
And those are fine,
but I would say
they're a little antiquated.
They're reliable for
particular classes of problems.
But for general
problems, you may not
have any idea whether
they're going to work or not.
Whereas method of lines may
be a really good approach
to a parabolic partial
differential equation
you're working with
where you can just
rely on the adaptive
time stepping and the air
control and an ODE-IVP solver to
keep everything stable in time
as you integrate forward.
We did application of
commercial software.
So you used COMSOL
to solve a problem.
I don't know.
Would you say was COMSOL
easier to use than writing
your own MATLAB code?
Harder to use than writing your
own MATLAB code, do you think?
No.
AUDIENCE: Easier.
PROFESSOR: Easier to use.
But the result, I
would say, wasn't
as good without some careful
refinement of the COMSOL
solution.
So for that particular
problem, if you
wanted a solution that looked
like your MATLAB solution that
was carefully resolved
in space, you really
had to go in and refine the
grid in particular places.
So it gets harder and harder
the more detail you want.
But it's an easy way
to get an answer.
You should check whether that
answer is right by comparing it
with other methods.
You can't guarantee
that it's giving you
the right result either.
To give you an example, I had
mentioned an unsteady advection
diffusion problem to
one of my grad students.
And he's very good with COMSOL.
I mentioned that it was a
hard problem because there
were boundary layers.
And the boundary layers
changed thickness and time,
and resolving
those things can be
quite challenging without
any physical insight.
And he says, well, I think
I can just do it in COMSOL.
And he tried it, and
COMSOL was happy to report
a solution in time and
space, but the solution
was nonsensical.
We could visualize
it and see that it
didn't look like what other
numerical solutions look like,
and in certain limits,
didn't correspond
to what those solutions are
known to be in those limits.
So the black box is great in
that it reports an answer.
But it can also be really
problematic as well.
So maybe, you have
expertise with COMSOL.
You can get a
solution to converge
for a difficult problem.
But you should really
have other methodologies
that let you assess the
quality of that solution.
For simple problems,
simple elliptic problems
and simple parabolic
problems, it's
going to do great,
because it's built
to eat those for breakfast.
But for complicated
engineering problems,
you've got to vet
your solutions.
Oh, what didn't we cover?
We didn't talk about
hyperbolic equations.
Not really.
We talked a little bit
about advection equations,
which have a hyperbolic
character associated with them.
So you have like a
pulse of [? solute, ?]
and it's advected along in time.
And you want that
advection to be stable,
so you want to use things
like upwind differencing
to ensure that stability.
But there's a broader class
of hyperbolic problems
that relate to things
like the motion of waves
in elastic solids.
We don't typically encounter
those in chemical engineering,
but chemical engineering
is a broad discipline.
And maybe you're
engineering soft materials
for some sort of device.
And you want to look
at the elastic response
of that material.
The PDEs that govern that are
a completely different class
than the ones that
we typically look at.
They're not parabolic.
They're not elliptic.
They're hyperbolic, and they
are these wave-like solutions
associated with them.
They require their own
particular solution methods
in order to be
stable and accurate.
And then there are all
sorts of specialized methods
that are dreamed up
to apply to, maybe,
a broad class of
problems, but it's
kind of hard to ensure
that they're going to work.
But nonetheless,
you'll see a lot
of this out in the literature.
So there are things
called multi-grid methods.
They try to discretize a
partial differential equation
with different
levels of fineness.
And you use course solutions
as initial guesses for finer
and finer solutions in space.
For some problems,
this works great.
And in fact, you
can show that it can
work as well as is possible.
So depending on the
size of the problem,
say you have n points at which
you want to find the solution.
You can find it in order n
time with some of these methods
depending on the particular
problem you're looking at.
That's good.
But oftentimes, engineering
problems aren't of that sort.
There's something more
complicated going on.
And it's hard to ensure that
you get those sorts of rates
of convergence.
But nonetheless, they
exist and something
that we didn't cover
you should be aware of.
We did DAEs.
So now, we coupled ODE-IVPs with
nonlinear algebraic equations.
Most dynamic engineering
problems are of this type.
We showed that DAEs are really
an issue with model formulation
ultimately.
We write down
conservation equations,
and we write down
certain constraints
on those conservation equations.
The constraints can
be specifications
like we want particular flow
rates in certain places.
Or they can be fundamental.
They can be
thermodynamic constraints
on the coexistence of different
phases of a particular material
in a particular unit operation.
If we could solve
those constraints
for certain unknowns
and substitute them
in the equations, we might
be able to produce ODE-IVPs.
Probably we can't come
up with those solutions.
So instead, we've always
got this coupled system
of initial value problems
with nonlinear equations.
So you have that sort
of a circumstance.
How should you think about that?
One way to think
about it was to say
that the algebraic equations are
essentially infinitely stiff.
They have to be imposed
exactly at every time step.
That they never relax in time
with the finite time constant.
And so we knew that
those sorts of methods
are hard to resolve with
typical ODE solvers.
And we tried to assess that
by computing something called
the differential index.
So we asked how
many times do I have
to take derivatives of
the algebraic equations
or any new algebraic
constraints in order
to get a system of ordinary
differential equations
to represent the same model.
I may want to solve that
system of ordinary differential
equations.
Or I may just want to know
the differential index
so that I can choose a
particular method to solve
this problem.
We saw the higher the index
was, the more sensitive
the solution was
to perturbations
in different input variables.
So the differential index
played an important role
in telling us something
physical about the problem
and the responses that could
be elicited by DAE systems.
We also talked about
consistent initialization.
I need to prescribe
the initial conditions
for all the differential
and algebraic variables.
Can I prescribe any of
those independently?
Well, the answer is actually no.
Depending on the
differential index,
there are underlying
algebraic constraints
that have to be satisfied
at all points in time.
And if they're not, then that
can break the method that's
trying to integrate the DAE.
So you have to prescribe
the initial conditions
consistently.
If they're not
prescribed consistently,
and you go to a piece
of commercial software,
it may give an error.
It may tell you nothing.
You may get a reasonable result
or an unreasonable result.
It really depends
on the methodology.
So it's up to you
to know in advance
that this is an important
aspect of the problem.
We solved index-1
DAEs typically.
Index-2 DAEs can be
converted into index-1 DAEs
and solved pretty easily.
Index-3 and bigger DAEs
are difficult because
of their high sensitivities.
So there's special
software that's out there.
I mentioned some of it
during our DAE lecture.
And that's really what you
want to reach for if you
have a high index DAE.
Examples, we were able to
craft all sorts of examples
where we tried to do funny
things with causality, where
you tried to change the input
by affecting the output, which
doesn't make a lot of sense.
But that led to very
high index DAEs.
Mechanical systems often
have very high index DAEs
associated with the
mechanical constraints,
typically lead to index-3 DAEs.
So these pop up in places
that are important.
And being able to
look at the model
and assess the index of
it is kind of essential.
We did probability.
So the physical world
has inherent uncertainty.
It's not just uncertainty in
our ability to measure things,
but fundamental,
physical uncertainty
is built into the
world around us.
So measurements have
uncontrolled or even
uncontrollable sensitivities
to this uncertainty.
And we wanted to know
how to handle it.
So we talked about things
like sources of randomness.
We did fundamentals.
Maybe this overlapped
with 10.40.
But I think overlap is
good, because humans
tend to have bad intuition
about probability in general.
So we discuss probability
densities, means, covariances,
expected values,
joint probabilities,
conditional probabilities.
We talked about common
probability densities.
You covered the
central limit theorem.
You talked about the difference
between sample averages
and the population mean.
One thing that's important
that I don't think that gets
covered much in
detail, but if you're
going to be working with
randomness computationally,
oftentimes you have to
generate random numbers.
And you'd like to generate
good random numbers.
Turns out a computer doesn't
generate proper random numbers,
only pseudo random numbers.
And these generators
have various properties
associated with them.
And some of them are good.
And some of them are bad.
And you want to use good ones.
So if you have to
generate random numbers
for your research,
you'd like to know
that they are high quality, that
the sequence of numbers that's
being generated doesn't
repeat over the time
that you're using it,
that it won't overlap over
many different uses
of this methodology.
So high quality random
numbers are important.
We discussed models versus data.
So we wanted to regress,
estimate parameters
from the data.
We wanted to do things
like hypothesis testing.
I have a model.
Is the model consistent
with the data,
or is it not consistent
with the data?
So you covered
things like linear
and nonlinear least squares,
maximum likelihood estimates,
confidence intervals found using
the chi-square distribution.
We did Bayes' theorem and
Bayesian parameter estimation
as well, so a way of using prior
information about parameter
values to better
estimate the probability
that those parameters will
take on values given the data.
We didn't cover
design of experiments.
That's a 10.551 topic.
But there are specific ways that
one can design the experiment.
Which data values
do I take in order
to make the fitting
of parameters optimal?
And there are other
problems besides regression
that are important.
But we don't typically utilize
those in chemical engineering.
So one of those
is classification.
So if I have a series of
points, and I do regression,
I'm in some sense
asking for like what's
the best curve due to this
model that can be drawn
through those points, right?
What parameter values
give me the curve
that's closest to all these
points, that's least squares.
Classification
might ask instead,
what's the curve that divides
these points most evenly,
or sits furthest from all
these points in an equal amount
instead.
Which side of this line
do the points sit on?
Are they of type A or type B?
It's kind of a related
problem to regression.
But it's a different
sort of problem.
The same sorts of methods can
be applied to classification
that you apply to doing
regression and parameter
estimation.
It's an important problem.
And then we finished up
with stochastic simulation.
So you learned that
sampling of random processes
can be used for
engineering calculations.
And they're even
inherently random physical
processes that you might
want to model reliably.
So we did Metropolis
Monte Carlo.
This was a way of
basically computing
high dimensional integrals.
That's what it
boiled down to, where
we wanted to sample
from different places
in the domain, weighted by some
probability density function.
You did kinetic
Monte Carlo, which
is really a sort of
event-driven algorithm.
You are expecting that
certain events are going
to occur with certain rates.
They're actually
nonstochastic versions
of that, the same sort of
event-driven algorithm.
I know certain
things should happen
at certain points in time.
And rather than integrating
the dynamics of the system
all along these points in time,
I just advance the dynamics
until the next event occurs.
That event occurs.
I keep a list of what the
next event is going to be.
And I follow those events along.
So it could be something like
billiard balls on a table.
I know the trajectories
of the billiard balls,
given their position
and their momenta.
And all I need to do is keep
track of when they collide
and where they're
going to go next
and what the next
events are going to be.
Well, kinetic Monte
Carlo was the same thing,
except the events
are now stochastic.
They occur with
prescribed rates.
And so I just need the sample
from this distribution of rates
to get the right
sequence of events.
There's funny things
about kinetic Monte Carlo.
So applied to chemical kinetics,
you can estimate these rates
reasonably well.
You've got to know the rates
for this process to look right.
If you don't have
the rates correct,
or you don't have the relative
magnitudes of the rates,
then the simulation is
kind of meaningless.
The result is going to
be nonsense or garbage.
And so there's going to be
limitations on your ability
to do this based upon
how accurately you
can estimate these rates.
It also means that if you
know that there's disparities
in the rates, say
one rate is very high
and one rate is very low, you
can make certain assumptions
about the process.
So things that
happen very quickly
you may treat as though
there are equilibrated
and not try to resolve them at
all and look more at infrequent
processes that
occur, slower rates.
So the precision with which
you have to know these things
is important.
The relative rates
are what's really
important in these problems.
And you want to get
them right in order
to resolve these physical
processes correctly.
Then we discussed
molecular dynamics
after that, which is another
type of stochastic simulation
methodology.
Here you just
integrate the equations
of motion associated
with whatever
particles you're interested in.
Kinetic Monte Carlo
and molecular dynamics
are sort of fundamentally
far from equilibrium,
but may relax
towards equilibrium,
depending on what constraints
you put on the particular rate
processes that you're modeling.
Metropolis Monte
Carlo is usually
sampling an underlying--
if we're applying it
in the statistical
mechanical sense,
it's usually sampling an
underlying equilibrium
Boltzmann distribution.
So they often get used in
fundamentally different ways
as well.
We didn't cover stochastic
differential equations.
So depending on which
degrees of freedom
you want to represent in a
model like molecular dynamics,
there may be some
degrees of freedom
you simply don't care about.
But they have an
influence on the problem.
So in my research,
for example, we model
nanoparticles and particulates.
We're not very interested in
the details of the solvents
surrounding these particles.
There's a huge disparity
in length scales associated
with nanoparticles and
the molecular dimensions
of the solvent that
surrounds them.
The solvent has an
influence nonetheless.
It's fluctuating all the time.
Solvent molecules are
colliding with these particles,
and they're imparting momentum.
One way of resolving
a system like that
without having to look
explicitly at the solvent
is to try to integrate out
the solvent degrees of freedom
and treat those collisions
of the solvent with this
particle in a stochastic sense.
So at various points
in time, there's
momentum that's randomly
transferred to particles
dispersed in a solvent.
The physical manifestation
of that is Brownian motion.
When you look at small
particles in the fluid,
you see them diffuse
around, and that's
where that's coming from.
So you can simulate
processes like that
without having to
resolve molecular scales.
So as you go up in
scale, you integrate out
degrees of freedom,
but oftentimes, that
introduces inherent
stochasticity
in the underlying
dynamics of whatever
you're trying to model.
That's very interesting.
And then for Monte
Carlo methods,
there's advanced
sampling methods.
And we didn't discuss
any of these in detail.
But you saw some of
this with the model
you saw with the problem you
approached in your homework
where you had two
populations or two peaks
in the probability distribution
that were widely separated.
And it may be hard for
a Monte Carlo method
to traverse between those peaks.
And umbrella sampling as a
way of biasing the probability
distribution to make
those paths from one
peak to another more probable.
So it's just a way of
seeking out rare events
like the transitions
between these two
different populations.
And it's pretty
important, ultimately,
for exploring complex
high dimensional spaces.
But you have to
understand something
about the underlying
physics in order
to figure out the biases
needed to enhance the sampling.
So it's so quite complicated.
So I'll remind you.
Your final exam,
right, it's Monday.
It's in 56-154 at 9:00 AM.
Don't show up to Walker.
It's not going to be there.
It's three hours.
It's going to be comprehensive.
You can expect roughly one
problem each thematic topic.
We've written it now.
I think it's nine problems long.
So we're in the
process of revising it
for difficulty and time.
It's going to be
short answer format.
We sort of aim at 10 to
15 minutes per problem.
I think that's the sort of
frame you should be looking at.
The problems are
structured in such a way
that that's about how
long they should take.
You should use that to
guide your temporal budget
on the exam.
If it's taking too long,
switch to something else.
Don't let yourself get hung
up focusing on one thing.
Move around and come
back to it later.
There will be some fundamentals.
There's going to be some
translation of engineering
into numerics.
And there's going
to be some MATLAB.
So it'll look like a
blend of the first exam
and the second exam.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When you
say it's on MATLAB,
do you mean [INAUDIBLE] MATLAB?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: No computers.
PROFESSOR: No computers.
It's just write a little script.
We've asked problems
like that before.
It'll be of the same type.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You said
nine problems.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I think
there's nine, yeah.
Well, that's how many
we've written now.
I'm not planning
on writing anymore.
AUDIENCE: Plus or minus one.
PROFESSOR: Plus or
minus one, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh sure.
Listen, if we gave you nine
problems of the same length
as on the first two
quizzes, you wouldn't
get through the problem.
So they're not
written to be so long.
But there are multiple parts.
But multiple parts
are usually intended
to guide you to the
solution we're looking for.
Usually, we're testing for
a particular understanding.
It also helps you out when
there are multiple parts.
So there's lots of
partial credit available.
You don't have to
get the whole thing.
You've just got to get two
out of the three parts.
You did pretty good.
OK, more questions?
AUDIENCE: So when
you say short answer,
does that just mean that
similar types of problems
as what we had on the
first two quizzes.
They're just shorter.
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's right.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, they're not
multiple choice, true or false.
They're short answer.
You want to hit a level
of detail that shows us
you understand what you're
talking about, right.
We don't need pages of
information on these things.
But we need to have enough
information that we can
see you know what you're doing.
We're trying to assess your
understanding of the material.
That's all.
More questions?
No more questions, OK.
Well, good.
It's been a real pleasure
teaching you guys.
I'm really pleased with
the outcome of this course.
This is my third
time teaching it.
I think this is the
strongest group that I've
seen come through 10.34.
So you guys should be
really proud of yourselves.
Good, all right, good luck.